[Music]
my name is Kurt I'm a product manager at
Google I work on the healthcare and life
science team and I focus on cloud
healthcare API we're very lucky today to
be joined by David from Stratis medicine
CEO he'll be speaking in a little bit
and let me also say actually before we
jump in
I must freely admit we were just talking
about this when David and I saw that we
were at the 5:00 p.m. slot and not in
the main venue we were more than a
little concerned that no one would show
up so I just want to thank everyone from
the bottom my heart for now forcing us
to stand up here and talk to an empty
room so thank you in today's session
we're gonna be talking about three
things in the first bit I'm gonna focus
on the role that cloud healthcare API
has in healthcare infrastructure to
approach again server list service
machine learning I'll then talk about a
general solution architecture that we
use and we take with customers who are
looking to implement a similar solution
and then I'm gonna hand over to David
who's going to talk about with a heavy
dose of pragmatism and insight from the
field what this looks like in a real
deployment so let's get started I think
it's useful in healthcare to help
contextualize conversations about caring
for patients working with providers in
the context of in this case a nurse so
this is Christy she's formerly an ICU
nurse currently a nurse practitioner and
those of you in the front row here may
notice that Christy bears a striking
resemblance to me it's a keen
observation christy is in fact my little
sister Oh
now the reason I mentioned that is
Christy and I had this little game we
play of one-upsmanship at family
gatherings and such where she tells me
all the things that she's seen in
clinical settings and I try and counter
with all the things I've seen in
healthcare IT and needless to say you
know Christy again I see you rolling
inside and out of the Edie Christy has
seen things and Christy usually wins but
I asked her you know hey I'm gonna be
giving this talk I'm gonna be talking
about data-driven problems can you give
me some examples where you think there
ought to be more data in the EHR your
medical record system and you just can't
quite find it at the moment
you need to make a decision and she
looked at me and sort of said well you
know side we're to even want to start
and I mean when all of us in this room
are familiar with healthcare IT and
clinical decision support cognitive
assistants you quickly realize there is
an abundance of opportunity here there
are thousands of problems that need to
be solved and let me give you a couple
examples in this case assume there's a
small inpatient clinic relatively rural
doesn't have a lot of specialists or to
the extent it does they only visit once
a week this is problematic because if a
patient is admitted gets their usual
labs and it shows an elevated troponin
troponin is an early indicator for
cardiac arrest the question is that
doesn't always happen so should you
refer this patient from this rural care
facility to a larger care facility that
has cardiac specialists
I don't know I'll give you another
example assume a patient patient just
suffered from a cerebral vascular
accident it is stroke so laying in the
bed just recovering one physician says
oh we need to keep the blood pressure up
we need to basically soak the brain and
blood oxygen rich blood help it recover
now the physician says no no no look at
the CT scan look at that see that bulge
by the heart if we keep the blood
pressure up we're gonna shear the aorta
what do you do what should the blood
pressure be right these are just two
examples of the myriad of problems that
exist in clinical decision making and
the question is is there data or is
there a process to sift through the data
and arrive at a support and a solution
that can augment and extend the
clinician and I want to touch on a paper
this was a paper actually presented when
I introduced healthcare epi last year at
next I mentioned this paper because of
the time that had just come out this is
a paper for my blue lay eye team and it
shows among other things that first of
all you can map a bunch of data to fire
welcome back to that in a second but
secondarily it shows that having mapped
your data to fire you could make highly
sensitive and specific predictions for
adverse clinical outcomes so again I
mentioned that last year since last year
we've been working with customers and
partners to start to bring these tools
into clinical workflow one of those
examples I've highlighted here this
one's public so again not disclosing
anything it's already public but this is
with our partnership we worked with
Emory
institution in the United States where
they had a an issue with blood borne
infection in their ICU so sepsis now
there are a lot of algorithms out there
for addressing sepsis but they had a
particular set of conditions that meant
they needed to build a model this team
saw the work and saw tensorflow and said
hey could I build a pipeline like that
could I ingest my labs and vitals could
I deploy a solution and in fact they did
and not only did they do it they then
want a grant from the HHS Health and
Human Services to expand the program
hisses grapes it shows that this
pipeline is actually feasible in real
clinical settings so with that in mind
right so I've set up the problem I'm not
described why are we even approaching
this problem why are we building what
we're building and I think this is where
I want to shift into talking about cloud
healthcare API and I think I think a lot
of people who approach data science and
especially data science in medicine you
go into it this mindset that there are
these three phases right these are
common to any data science project
discovery model training model
deployment the question is for people
who are newer are these equal in time
most people who are again new to the
field say oh yeah sure you know I'll
just do some discovery I'll train a
model to play it these are not equal in
time in fact most of us in this room who
have lived this experience know that we
spend an enormous amount of time and
energy in that first spot in discovery
training turns out to be the easy part
training to be turns out to be the part
that goes fast and then there's
deployment yeah there's a lot of issues
around patient safety and security of
the data but the end of the day it still
pales in comparison to the amount of
time we're spending in discovery put
this problem with slightly different way
on the one hand you've got all these
clinical systems that institutions have
been investing in for the last 10 20 30
years you've got them over here they're
largely on-prem over here you've got
this thing called cloud and cloud is
fabulous College where we got 10 to flow
at scale cause we've got chips designed
to run tensorflow
clouds where we have bigquery running
but there's this enormous gulf between
these two worlds because you can't just
rip these systems out and move in the
cloud so the question is how do we fill
that gap and that's the role of the
healthcare API the whole purpose of the
healthcare API is to help bridge these
existing systems
with the capabilities of Google cloud
and in particular and I like to
emphasize this point because it's often
lost in these discussions at the end of
the day we see an important step in
deploying healthcare API is that we need
to necessarily speak and support the
formats and protocols that are already
native to the industry data that these
institutions already have they're
already generating because if we can
speak these formats and protocols we can
bring this data into Google and into
cloud specifically and again this
touches on this our particular topic
today in our specific use case we want
to apply a variety of analytics machine
learning services to this data which
again the role of healthcare p.i is to
facilitate that integration now briefly
I just want to touch on this to answer
the question I get a lot of question
that well where does this fit in the
Google product roadmap in terms of
platform the service is a gmail right
fully managed or fully managed by Google
SAS is that raw infrastructure of rock
cloud VMs on so forth on GC on compute
engine and it really sits in the middle
it shouldn't really matter from your
perspective if you're throwing one
resource in 100 million resources in one
DICOM image 100 million cycle images it
should scale transparently for you
that's our goal now from an API
perspective we call it cloud healthcare
API because it's very much an API
surface you have this hierarchy of your
project right you control the project
within your project you specify location
this is critical in healthcare because
that's informs the API for where to
store data for the rest of that path you
have you create a data set a data set is
a grouping of multiple modalities of
data so you can have imaging data over
here and fire data here and fee to date
over here for clinical messaging and
finally you have your stores right
stores implement the modality-specific
API and I emphasize the point that it's
an API because if you're building an
application you're just addressing an
API and a very familiar way this is no
different than any other API you
interact with the key difference is that
under the hood it's scaling and
implementing these specific modality
datatypes for healthcare and of course I
would be remiss I don't want to spend
too much belabor the point we have
entire sessions on this topic but I do
want to emphasize this whole
architecture is designed to support the
storage of protected health information
so yes it is covered by our business
associates agreement ok now
I love this slide and every time I show
this slide oh so boring Kurt why do you
put this in your decks and I like it a
lot because what it shows in four
commands let me explain what's going on
in this example here but in these four
examples it shows oh we created the
dataset using G cloud or CLI we've
created a V to store for clinical
messages we've created a DICOM store for
clinical imagery and we've created a
fire store for fire data and we did this
in four commands and it doesn't matter
again you can send it one image one
hundred one hundred thousand images we
have I take the fact that it's boring as
a compliment we have made the ability to
create this infrastructure so boring
that this is the trivial part of the
process and that's great the more and
more we can make this type of work
mundane the more time developer teams
that we work with can span in the
application space helping patients
helping providers and that's where the
value is going to come from and briefly
I just want to cover some of the
configuration options these end up to be
useful and I'll cut you'll see why as
they start to talk about the solution
architecture but in this particular case
when we're talking about an hl7 B to
store there is one configuration option
for segment term is I don't spend too
much time on that but for those who have
deployed v2 in the field know that you
can configure that in a V to store the
piece I want to mention explicitly here
is that every single store in called
health KPI can be associated with a pub
subtopic this becomes important I'll get
to this in a minute DICOM same idea how
it can be a search to the pub sub topic
every time a new image is sent to a
DICOM store it generates a notification
saying hey I got a new image
same thing with fire you look at a fire
store fire we have a number of
parameters that we support for various
fires very complex spec so I don't want
to dwell in the spec itself but the
things when you're looking at the fire
specification know that the different
parameters there in the spec can be
tuned via configuration on the store
again the important point that I want
emphasized for art's discussion
discussion today is the fact that you
can associated pub sub topic with the
store so what do I mean by that again
you have your healthcare store it stores
healthcare specific data when data is
written when data changes generates a
notification - cloud pub/sub that
triggers a series of notifications at
any number of applications that you
build can be subscribed to and from
there this is an example of what that
message looks like so it's just like any
other pub/sub message namely there's a
data element that's basics for encoded
like all pub/sub messages on google
cloud that contains the
half of the resource that changed so any
subscribed application can grab the data
that changed this will become an
essential point in a second now
I emphasized earlier that it's just an
API so to get data in and out you simply
call the API in this particular case we
have a sample resource we're gonna pull
it out for some application that's great
now this is where things get interesting
I said at the beginning one of the part
one of the key roles of called
healthcare API is the ability to export
data and project it from its native data
type to bigquery so you can run sequel
based analysis against it that again is
just an API method you you invoke on the
store say hey take this fire data
projected to bigquery
take this daikon data project the
metadata to bigquery and that under the
hood will trigger a job that we project
that to your own bigquery store for the
case of fire there's a Community
Supported specification for an
analytical schema we implement this
specification so to the extent possible
this is an important point we are
implementing industry standard
specifications on Google cloud
technology so again the projection is
based on this schema and to trigger it
you just said an additional parameter
highlighted in blue on this slide to say
I want my projection to follow the
analytical schema based on the community
spec last point I want to make about
interaction with the firestore is that
all of these fire stores rather can
export and import directly to bigquery I
should actually should mention this
point earlier they can export and port
bigquery and be connected to your
business intelligence tools so you've
got R you've got tableau you've got all
these services that you're used to
running they can interact directly with
that projected data so you don't have to
teach your data science team to use a
different tool to connect to the
projected data there's the point is
trying to make when you're ready to
export your data for the purpose of
training a model we have a convenient
API call to let you say hey store take
all my data and drop it in a bigquery
and you can see again through a single
API call that that method will take your
data whether it's the DICOM data or v2
data or fire data export it to cloud
storage in this particular case so you
can train the model or in case you
wanted to move it to back on Prem or
take it from on Prem and shove it in the
cloud healthcare EPI all of this is
possible as an API method
now I last point I wanna make before we
dive into a solution architecture is to
talk about the fact that it's in beta
finally yay
over the last year one point of emphasis
has been performance one of the point of
emphasis has been conformance so those
are the two things that our team is
largely focused on and again I mention
this before it's in scope for the BAA
and importantly for term service okay so
I've set the stage for why cloud
healthcare API I want to spend a little
bit of time now talking through the
architecture for how we help these teams
deploy a solution which sets the pattern
that you'll see repeated when David
speaks about his particular
implementation so before I dive into
that there is one essential point I like
to make because this is a recurring
theme as we talk about these
implementations and that is namely the
focus on fire so fire serves two
important roles in our approach and that
is namely it's a very extensible data
model which is incredibly convenient the
second is that it's a graph so any graph
based querying and technology use can
work against fire data and then third is
actually the fact that it's also an API
specification so you can use it as a
transactional target in addition to
being the target for labeling and
training data also there's a reason this
actually came out last week CMS
announced that they're transitioning
some of their services over the next few
years not immediately but the initial
wave the demo was released last week so
you can actually extract claims data in
fire bulk format for those of you who
are paying attention to the regulatory
environment during hims you probably
also notice that both CMS and ONC
released proposed rules with a very
heavy emphasis on exposing api's the ONC
rule 700 pages
mentioned fire three hot little over
three hundred times right so there's a
clear both data science reason to be of
taking this approach and a clear push
from the regulatory environment to say
maybe this is something worth
investigating further for the purpose of
our conversation today I'm going to talk
about a very specific implementation and
that is something called c.d.s hooks in
the clinical space CVS hook is one
implementation of clinical decision
support there of course many best
practice alerts flowsheet integrations
Clin kb integrations the point is there
are a lot of disparate integrations that
are possible I'm going to focus on this
pattern because I want
set up the discussion for what you'll
see when David presents his work but a
CD s hook is fundamentally no more than
a web hook so it triggers an alert a
hospital an event occurs inside a care
facility that triggers an alert just
like any other web hook you're used to
now in the case of a CD s hook there are
a number of events that trigger that a
patient view is the most commonly
implemented to the extent CD s hooks are
implemented but there's others when an
order was reviewed a medication
prescribed the order select and down
which I've put in grey those are
technically in the spec we haven't seen
them widely implemented but I mentioned
them in the interest of thoroughness now
the CVS hooks service is in turn
expected to respond with a payload
that's designed to trigger a native
rendering in the source EHR so in the
case of Cerner there's a specific UI
element that gets rendered when this Web
hook is answered this gives you at least
for the purpose of our discussion a
target when we're talking about an
architecture for delivering clinical
decision support cognitive assistance
into workflow the other convenient
property about it which I like for
discussion and developer purposes is
that there's an open sandbox so you
could leave the session go test it on
the stand box that's developed by
Cerner's the CERN is one the larger EHR
vendors in the world they have a to
process to just test these locally again
convenient when you're doing development
activities so let's return to the three
phases I setup at the beginning you have
discovery you have training and you have
deployment in the case of discovery we
actually spent a lot of time on this
already right I talked about the ability
to project data from the healthcare EPI
to bigquery so you're ingesting these v2
messages you're ingesting as fire data
the DICOM data and you want to project
it for the purpose of discovering what
are some abnormalities in my data
connector our process to do some sifting
around or do I have some biases
expressed because of my collection
procedures right all that work is
enabled through your projection in the
bigquery for training this is another
area which I'll point you to some open
source work that our friends at Google
AI have performed there's a whole step
by step process we've identified which
is again we've tested a number of
scenarios but the idea is how do we take
fire data how do we label it annotate it
and then how do we train a model this
has a step-by-step guide on how you
would do that after exporting the data
and the basic flow which I'll cover for
the purpose of when you're deploying it
on cloud did you take your fire data you
export it to GCS
you then label it however you see fit
using the again the tools that I just
showed in last slide and you create a
model which you can upload to ml Engine
now the nice thing about the the work
that the AI team showed on the last
slide was that that also works locally
so if you're looking to develop this
kind of tooling you can test it directly
on your machine now in terms of
deployment
we're largely talking about ok how do we
implement this c.d.s look how we're
going to build a solution that pieces
together various parts of cloud in a way
that answers that Web book request
so in this particular case I've used the
kubernetes engine logo for this EHR
relay and that's because you're going to
be ingesting clinical data somehow and I
say somehow because for the purpose of
our example what we want is a stream of
fire observations we all know there are
very few EHR systems streaming fire
observations today which are
realistically getting is an hl7 v2
message streaming labs and vitals in
this case I used to know are you for an
example so the question is ok great now
how do I turn that into a fire
observation there is some work on our
side for ingesting hl7 B to message a
Mis and open source project that speaks
mllp so minimum lower layer protocol is
the protocol necessary to ingest v2
messages we have an open source
container that you can run on kubernetes
engine that's why use the Careers engine
logo earlier to ingest these clinical
messages now we also work with partners
so you may have interface engines in
your institution today that are capable
of directly integrating with called
health KPI one of them this is a team we
work with built a integration for mirth
or next-gen to ingest v2 messages
directly from an existing mirth
installation so that a system that
already invested in mirth next slash
next-gen could easily connect their data
to cloud so somehow someway using either
of those services or when your existing
interface engines your streaming v2
messages to cloud health KPI and I
mentioned earlier that is connected to
pub sub this is the essential feature
because now you're getting it you have a
mechanism to know when new data was
written to your v2 store and because you
haven't mechanism to know that you can
ultimately trigger data flow again
either directly or this is an area of
investment for our team or how can we
make this more of a managed service but
that Maps that B to data grabs the
message and turns it into a fire
observation right so this is the target
somehow you have this little engine
that's mapping v2 messages to fire on a
real-time basis so we go back to the
example where let's assume for the sake
of argument and for the sake of my
diagram that were streaming observations
from my source which may be this data
flow process under the hood now we'll go
back to the notification idea so now
you've got these out fire observations
being rent to the store again you can
lean on the fact that pub/sub is sending
out notifications about this new data so
your cloud function can directly attach
and why it's called function necessary
here well because somehow you need to
invoke the model with the right fire
data so because the pub/sub notification
contained information about what fire
resource was mutated it can grab the
patient everything bundle from health
care epi which effectively is a
representation everything about that
data and send it off to ml engine for
prediction once it receives that
prediction it can then generate a risk
assessment and write the risk assessment
back to the fire store so now you've got
this pipeline of you're ingesting data
the model that you trained in phase 2 is
running on ml engine looking at the
patient everything bundle which you
again trained using a tensor flow
sequence example and it's generating a
prediction which you're converting into
a risk assessment so that whole process
is running asynchronously right that's
as new data streaming in that whole that
whole engine is churning but now you've
got the CD s-hook component because this
the hospital says oh I have a new
patient or of clinician looks at a
patient that triggers a notification to
a cloud function because for those
promote called functions one of the
triggers you can use is an HTTP
invocation so now it's oh I got a web
book request from this hospital I know
how to handle this let me reach out to
the call of healthcare API grab the risk
assessment and format my payload nice
skipped over the fact that CTS hook has
an authentication authorization step but
that's in there that would be in your
business logic for the called function
but what you're generating here is now
you've got that asynchronous loop
running generating risk assessments and
a synchronous loop to inspect the data
and generate a response for the care
facility in the immediate workflow again
I want to point of emphasis we have an
open source project that shows how that
pipeline is built this project actually
also has a UI though I want to caution
people what this demo does is it says
I'm going to go to the country X do I
need an immunization
that is not a great problem for machine
learning freely admit that and the
reason is because if you're gonna go to
country X you would simply consult your
relevant Authority and get your
appropriate immunizations you don't
really want to predict that but the
underlying pipeline is the same and so
we wanted to pick a topic where it was
clear that the pipeline is feasible to
show you how the pieces fit together
even if the problem space should you
should not get immunization is
relatively trivial that pipeline is
consistent across all the
implementations of the solution that
we've seen also for imaging data I have
focused on fire and clinical data for
the purpose of this discussion but
there's a collab also available on
github for running this exact same flow
except using imaging data so again
whether you're using streaming clinical
data or data from an EHR you have a
consistent system and architecture to
apply that's able to generate these
sensitive and specific predictions and
with that I went ahead over David who's
going to talk about this in practice hi
my name is David verdict and I'm the CEO
of Stratis medicine at Stratis medicine
we partner with health systems to help
them accelerate their innovation
programs we leverage technology and data
science to really make impact in
healthcare and I'm going to talk to you
today about a case study where we've
actually applied these healthcare API
tools so like I mentioned we applied
technology and data science to
healthcare and we've worked with both
internal innovation teams and external
vendors and we're leveraging medical
records and genomics images and machine
learning methods to really impact
clinical care clinical decision support
health system administration and what
we've seen frequently is that innovators
in this space don't have access to the
tools that would really accelerate their
workflows you know it's oftentimes
relative to data security data use and
privacy which are all very important
things so how can we help healthcare IT
move to the cloud right right now
they're in this world of virtual
machines they've built a nice security
workflow it works for them the
boundaries are well diffract defined but
they can't incrementally move towards
infrastructure as a service or platform
as a service where there's a lot of
value
because ad-hoc use is risky you're not
going to turn your developers loose with
an API key and in fact when you do you
get things like the data breach it u-dub
medicine this spring which I was
involved in well my name was involved in
where somebody just put a bunch of about
a millions patients million patients
worth of data into an unsecured cloud
bucket and Google indexed it so you know
it's expensive for IT to productize what
the public clouds have created it's hard
for them to support new trends like
serverless or kubernetes and so our
viewpoint is that you really want health
care to jump from the VM you know gen to
computing world to a
software-as-a-service product that wraps
up the public cloud offerings into kind
of an opinionated workflow that's
specifically tailored to health club
health care and healthcare application
deployment so now what we can help
health systems do is create a secure
workflow for application development and
deployment enforce security best
practices do active breach prevention
and because a lot of health systems
don't want to hire data scientists and
software engineers in-house we can
provide professional services for that
so if we stand on the shoulders of the
public clouds with their infrastructure
and platform as a service and we narrow
that down to a specific SAS offering
then we can focus on applications that
provide real clinical value and we want
the team's building those to be able to
iterate quickly and not do it with
specialized skills so let's talk more
about how we can do innovation with
these modern tools and specifically
clinical decision support so for the
last five years we have been a strategic
partner of the Sun yet sand Cancer
Center in Taiwan they're one of the
premier cancer centers in Asia they have
a 325 bed hospital that provides both
inpatient and outpatient oncology care
and what's really interesting is they
have been operating profitable bundled
payment for over 18 years
these are five-year long episodes of
care and in doing that you know their
outcomes are as good or better than top
US institutions in doing that they've
seen what the keys to success are in the
value-based care world they need to
leverage data appropriately have really
good care management
and effective use of their resources
both in terms of what treatments they
use and the use of their staff so the
case study that we're going to talk
about is distant metastasis in breast
cancer so distant metastasis is when a
breast cancer spreads to other organs
and the typical progression goes like
this you have the initial adjuvant
treatment so that is now your first-line
treatment and then in some patients
unfortunately the cancer spreads to
other organs there's a regimented
follow-up so every three months
initially then six months but
unfortunately there is this period
there's this kind of problem here where
the cancer spreads but the patient might
come into the clinic before a regularly
scheduled follow-up with some symptoms
and are those symptoms related to a
recurrence or they just pneumonia or
some other comorbidity so it's up to the
physicians discretion to say well should
I use advanced imaging right that's
expensive and invasive imaging maybe a
chest x-ray and determine is this
related to their breast cancer that they
had four years ago or is this just
something else so how do we help
physicians make that decision and how do
we standardize that across the different
medical oncologists in the group so the
goal here is to create kind of the
earliest identification of recurrence
and follow-up and we'll create a model
that stratifies the risk of recurrence
for each individual patient with the
result being that we have effective and
efficient use of advanced imaging and we
can reduce by three to six months the
time from the actual cancer recurrence
to start meant of recurrence treatment
so generically the process looks like
this we have a die comstor for images we
leverage fire for modeling the medical
record and we use registries for curated
parts of the medical record we take
these three data sources feed them into
a machine learning framework and bring
actionable insight to the clinician
let's focus a little bit on fire and
registries so like I said we're gonna
model the entire medical record in fire
here and then we'll use the registries
that are extracted from that medical
record to be a you know a specific
clinical area so in breast cancer this
would be what are the patient
demographics
what is the pathologic staging for that
tumor what was the initial adjuvant
treatment and then what is their stage
of recurrence right have they had a
local regional recurrence have they had
a distant metastasis these registries
are super valuable to the Sun yat-sen
they use them for retrospective analysis
and things like SAS and tableau they use
them for training models and they use
them for billing because when you're in
a value-based care reimbursement program
you need to use kind of these deep
pieces in the medical record in your
billing so what is fire probably most
people are familiar with it but if
you're not it is an hl7 specification
that both models medical records data
and also provides an API it's a directed
graph of resources and these resources
are things like the patient practitioner
diagnostic report medication
prescription and you know fire means a
lot of things to different people it
says young inspect less than a decade
and it was originally built for health
information exchange so some people view
it as health system to health system a
lot of people with apples entrance to
the market view it as a
direct-to-consumer model but I think
that has real value for data science and
so because it can really help us
standardize our data engineering
workflows it's a well-documented
specification where canonical data is
stored in a really consistent location
throughout the spec so for example
here's a procedure resource and the
procedure resource has subject key which
is who the procedure was performed on it
also has a key for the code which is the
identification of the procedure and we
would like it to be a snow med CT
ontology that describes that and there's
just one of them and has codable concept
the nice thing about that is that we
don't need a data analyst to work hand
in hand with our programmers to
understand the data to build
applications on top of the medical
record one organization that we've
worked with had a very large their
medical record had a very large oracle
schema all the tables were eight
characters long and all caps of course
and you know the knowledge built into
that schema to get the data out we
needed to create clinical applications
was was very very deep right
you don't want that to impede every one
of your developers experience in
accessing data to build applications
another great use of fire is to
normalize variability from data sources
so whether you're combining legacy data
sources or you're combining the data
warehouse with a real-time store you can
use fire and its model to just normalize
the data input and have a consistent
data engineering workflow like I
mentioned creating structured registries
from fire is really valuable of course
in the healthcare API is you can dump
directly to bigquery but as most people
working in the field know a lot of value
is in unstructured data in medical
records and so working with health
systems we found that there's a lot of
value in writing very small targeted
programs that leverage natural language
processing or parsing multiple ways
where you can just write these ad hoc
programs to create highly structured and
really valuable datasets so now that
I've told you why fire is so great let
me tell you why scalable fire
implementation is difficult the
specification is really a deeply nested
data structure and when you try and
model this relationally you end up with
hundreds of tables and thousands of
foreign keys and if you try and lay an
ORM on top of this you can quickly
overrun the databases capacity to do
select queries because of a lot of that
deep backlinking the spec also you know
these references between this graph of
medical record models is essentially a
generic foreign key and so you have a
ton of generic foreign keys which again
is really hard to deal with at a
scalable implementation level so we were
actually talking about building a fire
on top of spanner when I came across the
Google healthcare KPIs and what's great
about this is that they already did it
for us
it's a standards compliant hl7
implementation and so essentially we can
just drop this in into any of our
previous fire implementations we don't
have to take something off the shelf
manage the index size manage the
database size it's fully managed and
high scalability and this is just an
example of how I think that
you know platform-as-a-service for
healthcare it can really accelerate it
right we're not doing the nuts and bolts
of building our infrastructure we step
back and look at imaging in healthcare I
think in imaging is interesting because
it's one you know it genomics are one of
the few high dimensional data sources in
healthcare so that's where we can really
extract insight with machine learning so
of course we can label our images and
build a classifier in this case it would
be in mammography and we can take
tensorflow off the shelf we can train a
model and we can spin up a tensor flow
server or use ml engine to serve our
model and you know off we go
but the problem is that data sets in
healthcare are small there's not a lot
of health information exchange there are
no national aggregations that are widely
accessible and so transfer learning is
really key in healthcare if you're not
familiar what transfer learning is
especially in the context of images so
where you kind of stand on the shoulders
of a previous convolutional neural
network and then you tack your model
onto the end and so what's encoded over
there say like Inception v3 from image
net is you know what are the features of
an image generically can we take
millions or billions of images and and
do you know line detection feature
detection and then we'll just tack our
model onto the end of it again we'll
stick our huge team of data scientists
inside our health system onto that model
and then deploy it but as you guys
probably guess there's not a huge team
of data scientists at every health
institution so how do we do this quickly
how do we iterate and leverage machine
learning on this high dimensional data
for us we found a lot of value in auto
ml vision so autumn ml vision automates
that whole process for you you don't
need special you know specialized tensor
flow of knowledge to be able to train a
model on your DICOM images the DICOM api
also does a nice thing which is
transcode your DICOM images into JPEGs
which you need to do for training and
then once it trains and you find the
right level of sensitivity and
specificity it automatically deploys
your model for you so now that we have
our tools together we're gonna use the
DICOM api for image
use the fire API for a fire store we use
cloud sequel for registries you could
also use bigquery and automail vision
let's talk about how we're actually
building this in an architectural level
so this is work that's in progress at
the Sun yat-sen now and if you've ever
built an ETL on healthcare data you know
that it's a real challenge you want it
to be very robust you don't want to have
missing data and so how you do that can
be a little bit tricky our opinion is
that you want to write once and succeed
you don't want to have a chatty API you
really want the rate limiter to be your
internal system and in this diagram I'm
going to use blue arrows to denote a
pub/sub asynchronous message queue just
for clarity so let's say we write a fire
resource into cloud storage it kicks off
a message into a pub sub and the nice
thing about asynchronous message queues
is that you'll get durable delivery
right it's at least once delivery but at
least once means that it's maybe twice
or maybe three times so we'll leverage
cloud dataflow which will give us
exactly once delivery and that's where
we'll write our deduplication will
leverage the fire specs use of
identifiers to query the fire API for
example for this patient say hey do you
have this patient with this MRN if so
create it or if not create it if so
update it and similar for the DICOM
store from there when we create that
resource in the fire store that kicks
off an asynchronous message that cloud
function consumes and updates the
registry and I can't emphasize enough
how important having a living registry
is that's constantly being updated that
is a huge value for a health system both
in retrospective and analytics and also
for machine learning so now that we have
all of our medical record and our images
in we can use the firestore and the
registries to create a training test and
validation data set hand that bulk over
to auto ml vision and have it train a
model so now we're all ready to go a new
let's say a new fire resource comes in
through the API or in this case a new
image lands in the DICOM store
again we get an asynchronous message
that is consumed by a cloud function
that will actually run our model and
deliver it so we use the cloud function
to look into the registry and select
appropriate models for this patient and
for the image type we then run that
model in Auto ml vision and we use an
asynchronous queue to deliver it back to
the health systems EHR that surfaced
clinically in the workflow and you know
what we have built here is an entirely
serverless system that is easy for us to
iterate and create new clinical decision
support products on we just have to
essentially do that upfront investment
in ETL so what we found that the key to
successful innovation is that you need
to have a SAS cloud work row right you
can't do everything yourself and if you
if you can if you can make a secure
workflow that allows you to access these
cloud tools all of a sudden now number
two you can move fast with these
platform as-a-service things that I've
been talking about you're not
reinventing the wheel you're not running
in a database you're not taking a fire
store off the shelf and so now that you
can quickly create healthcare specific
applications you're able to leverage
your expertise in-house right the hard
work is to empower individuals in your
organization to solve clinical problems
and without specialized skills to really
improve the patient experience and
health system operations
[Music]